meine gäste vorstellen ludmilla melnik
ist bei uns sie ist ukrainerin sie
arbeitet am institut für europäische
politik dort leitet sie ein deutsch
ukrainisches forschungsprojekt und sie
moderiert den podcast ukraine nehmen
herzlich willkommen ich begrüße
christoph von marschall diplomatischer
korrespondent der chefredaktion des
tagesspiegels
zugeschaltet in moskau ist als life
berlioz leiter des zentrums für
deutschland studien an der russischen
akademie der wissenschaften und herzlich
willkommen eric kirschbaum
us-amerikanischer freier journalist er
schreibt unter anderem für die los
angeles times
herr von marschall das ist eine sehr
ernste lage wir haben den bundeskanzler
eben gehört sehr ernste worte die ganze
welt ist so ein bisschen aufruhr wie
hoch schätzen sie die gefahr eines
krieges 1 in europa ich glaube das kann
man immer noch nicht sagen das ist
letzten endes wladimir putins
entscheidung aber wir müssen schon damit
rechnen dass er meint was er gesagt hat
und die gestrige rede war wirklich
besorgniserregend es geht ja nicht nur
um die ukraine sowie ihr das gesagt hat
der gesamte ehemalige sowjetische raum
steht zur disposition
darüber hinaus hat er sich auf die
herrschaft russlands während des
zarenreichs berufen dass wurde finnland
ein eu-land einschließen es wurde polen
einschließen das würde die baltischen
staaten einschließen also es ist sehr
sehr beunruhigend und man muss ihm klar
entgegen treten dieses jahr wird zu
einem zäsur ja in der europäischen
nachkriegsordnung diese dimension des
rechtsbruchs den lade mir putin gerade
vorantreibt er spricht einer nation ihr
existenzrecht ab ihr eigenständigkeit
recht ab er verändert zum wiederholten
male mit gewalt grenzen das ist alles so
undenkbar gewesen dass er unterschätzt
wenn man das muss man rückblickend sagen
man hat ihn wohl unterschätzt und manche
fragen sich ja inwieweit wladimir putin
überhaupt noch kontakt zur realität hat
der ist ja seit über 20 jahren entweder
präsident oder ministerpräsident er ist
fast nur von gleichaltrigen umgeben also
menschen rund um die 70 die auch von ihm
abhängig sind und die alle in seiner
bisherigen kommen dinge verwickelt waren
so dass sie auch von dem abhängig sind
also es ist sehr sehr besorgniserregend
die ganze situation natürlich auch für
die menschen in der ukraine
was wie geht es ihnen seit gestern abend
was hören sie aus ihrem heimatland und
wie groß ist bei ihnen die angst dass es
tatsächlich zum krieg kommt ich glaube
auch der menschlichen ebene ist es sehr
schwierig viele haben gestern auch nicht
geschlafen kann ich mir vorstellen wenn
dir aber über die menschen sprechen dann
hat sich seit 2014 was verändert weil
der krieg dauert eigentlich seit 2014 in
der ukraine die menschen
bereiten sich auf verschiedene
krisensituationen voraus es gibt auch
jetzt verschiedene broschüren wie man
auch ihre kinder auf krisensituationen
vorbereiten soll
und ich glaube was
was in diesem zusammenhang wie immer
betonen sollen der krieg dauert schon
seit acht jahren und die menschen haben
schon langsam daran gewöhnt aber das was
wir gestern erlebt haben das hat auch
die ukraine in
versetzen gesetzt wir reden gleich
natürlich weiter darüber was die ukraine
erwartet gerade vom westen ich würd
gerne herrn bello fragen derweil um alle
sagen es ist ein klares klarer bruch mit
dem völkerrecht die eu hat jetzt scharfe
sanktionen auch beschlossen erklären sie
uns was will putin will putin einen
krieg in europa anzetteln
keinesfalls
beunruhigend
besorgniserregend ist die position etwas
her für masche jetzt auch dana uns
dargestellt hat
imperialistische absichten polen
finnland um gottes willen so versprechen
es geht um selbst muss teams recht nach
der satzung von gut steht vielleicht
jetzt in einem widerspruch nach essen
die akte mit die rituale und integrität
da haben die japanischen bürger aus den
bestimmten gründen 2014
das recht in anspruch genommen aber sich
für unabhängig von der
macht in kiew was
gegen die verfassung
die übernommen hat
für selbstständig erklärt und booten hat
diese publikum eigentlich schnell der
völkerrecht anerkannt wir können
natürlich darüber diskutieren aber
wenigstens mir diese anerkennung nach
acht jahren wo die deutschen hatten
sieben jahren hat der maske abkommen die
nicht von kiew zur zeit akzeptiert sind
er hat putin das gemacht und im grunde
genommen das ziel ist nicht ein krieg
zulassen zuzulassen b menschen leben
hier saubere viele danke für die frau
melnik der ausländer nicht nur die
ukrainischen bürger sondern auch die
bürger in beiden komiker nicht
geschlafen haben das jetzt zur
waffenruhe kommen sollte und bitte nicht
darüber sprechen dass die russischen
panzer irgendwann nach kiew kommen
sollten es geht um zwei republiken die
dann auch ihre ruhe brauchen und
eigentlich eigentlich auch das recht
darauf haben anerkannt zu sein ja ich
habe das ist auch eine völkerrecht
diskussion ist aber die gibt okay aber
sie wenn sie sagen es gibt es geht um
selbstbestimmungsrecht putin spricht der
ukraine ja das selbstbestimmungsrecht ab
wir stechen von den bürgern der ukraine
die aus den bestimmten gründen auch es
erklärt haben dass im staat sie auch
dann keine rechte haben und das ist ein
widerspruch und das ist im sinne wir
sprechen von zwei verschiedenen
unterschiedlichen dingen aber wie gesagt
booten möchte tag einen krieg und in
diesem sinne wenigstens schon jetzt von
im player im br listigen absichten
gelingt hier dann hier tnt dem den
objektiven sachen einfach vorbei also
und wir zwei verschiedenen stock essen
sagen putin will keinen krieg herr
kirschbaum wir am anfang dieser woche
habe er noch sehr stark auf die
diplomatie gesetzt man hat gedacht und
putin können sich treffen in der letzten
woche bundeskanzler scholz in moskau
rechnen sie noch damit dass es noch
irgendeine chance gibt dass man
diplomatisch noch etwas erreichen kann
ist die sind die amerikaner dazu noch
bereit
ja ich bin nicht in der regierung aber
ich glaube schon dass die mir gerade
werden alles tun um einen großen krieg
zu behindern und das ist natürlich die
interesse der amerikaner dass es kein
krieg hier gibt die wir sind in
washington ganz genau dass es viele
viele reli gegeben werden die wissen
auch dass diese westliche allianz
zusammen zu halten wird auch kein
pappenstiel sein wir haben heute gesehen
wo das kanzel chance hat endlich den das
wohl extremes freien den mund genommen
und sagt das projekt ist mehr oder sind
auf eis gelegt aber ganz technischen
verwaltungstechnisch hatte das gemacht
gar nicht so gar nicht so stark und
politisch wie joe biden das gemacht vor
der woche nein es ist immer noch zeit
für diplomatie und hoffentlich können
die diplomaten noch zeigen was die alles
machen können in den in den tagen und
wochen die noch kommen alle haben bei
der diplomatie auf das minsker abkommen
gesetzt hat wird das wäre noch eine
möglichkeit das wiederzubeleben da dem
mann putin aber heute eine klare absage
erteilt er hat ja heute auch noch mal
eine pressekonferenz gegeben ganz kurzer
ausschnitt daraus bitte
diese maske fallen darum die gibt es
nicht mehr hier soll warum sollen wir
die erfüllen wenn wir die unabhängigkeit
diese gebilde anerkannt haben also da
hat er gesagt ein paar schaut er hat
eben die republiken anerkannt und dann
braucht das münster abkommen nicht mehr
ist dass damit eben wirklich dann tot
oder gibt es da irgendeine chance und
das ist tot
so erklärt dass er keinen
verhandlungsspielraum da sieht das ist
ja interessant die frage nach ob der
westen noch verhandeln will wir wollen
die ganze zeit verhandeln putin nimmt
ständig dinge die ja zugesagt hat zurück
und ich wundere mich schon dass herr b
lauf und sie hier erzählt dass das
selbstbestimmungsrecht einzelner
separatisten durch die uno charta
gedeckt wird ich mein herze doch sie
wissen doch was überhaupt nicht stimmt
selbstverständlich sind separatisten
bewegungen nicht von dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht gedeckt und die
russland hat in mehreren verträgen die
integrität die grenzen der ukraine
anerkannt es hat diese zusagen die es in
vielen verträgen angefangen von der
charta von paris das memorandum von
budapest der nato russland vertrag
überall steht das drin dass russland die
grenzen der ukraine anerkannt und
berufen sie sich darauf dass man einfach
separatisten unterstützen können das ist
doch sowas von gegen das völkerrecht
dass die leute sich und uns das schloss
darzulegen das wundert mich schon sehr
und dann sagen sie wenn ich sage das was
putin gestern in seiner rede gesagt hat
dass er sich auch russische rechte aus
der zarenzeit beruf dann sagen sie ich
sollte man hier nicht übertreiben das
müssen sie doch erklären warum herr
putin das gestern gesagt hat und sie
jetzt behaupten das hätte er nicht
gesagt das ist doch widerspruch auf
widerspruch auf widerspruch vielleicht
können sie darauf reagieren jetzt können
auch zwischendurch meine karte
einblenden damit man doch mal sieht wo
diese es geht ja um diese beiden gebiete
in der ost ukraine luynes und don jetzt
und teile davon sind eben unter der
unter der stadt von separatisten er
werde auf ja was sagen sie dazu zu denen
was er was herr marshall jetzt sagt ich
mich in marshall vor beieinander also
indischen
1920 jahrhundert putin hat ganz klar
erzählt was die deutschen wissen was war
diese methode macht zehn sowjetunion die
freiwillig die grenzen verschoben hat
und das tun was kam zu keiner hat mir
nicht gesagt nur aus einem grund dass
die arbeiterklasse in der komischen
partei keine tatsächlich existierte
punkt also das war dann die geschichte
keine bezweifelt ukraine sowie der staat
ist klar aber bitte zu sehen wie das
alles im dezember 91 entstanden war
bitte dann auch tatsächlich sehen was
hat diese geschichte von 30 jahren wo
die blind bomben zeitpunkten in diesem
körper von politischen raum man
eingelegt hat und das gilt nicht nur der
ukraine es geht antrags nächste im
südkaukasus auch mittelasien usw also
man hat das nicht geregelt westen hat
hier super macho gesagt er gebeten hat
ihm zu helfen also das sollten wir dann
auch wissen und sehen november 1990 auch
darüber sprach platini putin nicht aber
keine ideale absichten zurückgekommen zu
kritischen bürgern zu bürgern nicht so
beim zubereiten zu menschen der dann
auch keine verbrecher sind sondern das
recht auf ihr eigenes leben haben und da
sollten wir tatsächlich dann auch mit
völkerrechtlichen fachleuten sprechen
was sind weiche die bewegungen
selbstbestimmung und sie kreativ das ist
aber dann sie haben sehr klar gemacht
dass eben kein ganz einfacher bellof hat
gerade gesagt dass aus seiner sicht
anerkannt ist dass die ukraine ein
souveräner eigenständiger staat ist
genau das gegenteil von dem was putin
gesagt hat putin hat gestern gesagt na
die ukraine ist ein konstrukt es ist
kein eigenständiger staat es ist nicht
mal ein eigenständiges volk was gilt
denn nun was sie sagen oder was ihr
präsident gestern gesagt hat vielleicht
erst romanik und
dann können sie nochmal reagieren was es
geht auch nicht um dann zarenreich es
geht wirklich um noch um das mittelalter
da gab es kiewer rus und ich glaube ein
großes territorium der kiewer rus das
ist aus dem elften jahrhundert
eigentlich ein
mittelalterliches reich befand sich auf
dem territorium der ukraine belarus und
zum teil august fand aber der größte
teil befinden sich auch bis heute
sozusagen das ist das erbe das ukraine
besitzt und ich glaube das ganze
territorium der ukraine ist für russland
identitätsstiftend und er hat das
gestern in seiner rede sehr gut
dargestellt dass er das gar nicht
anerkannt die ukraine als einen
selbstständigen staat er hat auch in
meinem artikel immer darauf hingewiesen
dass alle versuche
das die ukraine unternommen hat
unabhängig zu werden er hat das immer
als einfluss von außen dargestellt
sozusagen die ukraine kann nicht selber
regieren und wann war es dann kommen die
anderen und dann helfen das ist eine
meiner gefahr die wir und noch ein
anderer punkt der jetzt von booten auf
den tisch gelegt wurde und in diesem
marie tief
im kampf der innovative hatte zum ersten
mal denke ich überhaupt die rolle der
orthodoxie aufgenommen ich habe das
persönlich so zum ersten mal so erlebt
dass er ihn mal wieder darauf
hingewiesen hat und das ist für mich
schon
eine sehr gefährliche tendenz und ich
frage mich ob es wirklich nicht noch mal
dazu kommen würde dass man dann sagt wir
verteidigen auch russische orthodoxe
hinteren reihen herr bello was ist das
also will man was was will putin denn
wenn sie sagen die ukraine hat das
selbstbestimmungsrecht putin sagt das
ganz anders in seiner rede also was ist
denn dann das ziel
ja das nicht gesagt er hat die
geschichte sind wie dann auch
der ukrainische staatlichkeit entstanden
war und wie sie dann aussieht dass sie
auch in einem transit ist also das ist
auch dann in einem auge und keine
bestreite dass das ukrainische staat
existiert und was putin andeutet dass
ukraine abhängig ist von den ahnen was
auch verständlich ist das ist auch zur
zeit realität auch so eine frage ist wie
weit deutschland souverän ist oder
ostern syrien ist und so weiter so da
gibt es jemand die verpflichtung in
verbindungen und so weiter also noch
einmal putin möchte frieden ob das auch
der westen möchte oder nicht und wenn
wir dann auch sie in welchen unter
welchen druck russland im januar
angesetzt hat das war dann auch noch
eine frage inwieweit wir doch diese
völkerrechtliche dinge betrachten und
die szenarien die es vom westen
beschrieben worden waren als ob alle von
westen im kopf von puten waren dass
putin das möchte der hat das zählt usw
dann beneide ich die experten die das
genau auch möchten wir möchten
europäische sicherheit das ist dann auch
anrainerstaaten laut der reise hatte
dann auch ihre sicherheit nicht auf die
kosten von den anderen aufgebaut haben
und dass es ja klar dass ukraine jetzt
ein teil von infrastruktur von nato sein
könnte uns für russland ist nicht
akzeptabel
dass nicht zur diskussion das ukraine
mitglied der nato wird das geht ja gar
nicht zur diskussion
kurz vorm ich würde gern
wir sprechen darüber dass russland ist
es ja wichtig dass ukraine auch alles
sein partner nachbarn usw aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen kein
risiko entweder werde auch noch wer
dafür noch große los und darstellt das
ist
eine indirekte verbindung der kirschbaum
was ist jetzt nach was hat sich
verändert seit der rede von putin seit
der anerkennung der republiken wo wie
würden sie sagen
wie stellen sich die amerikaner jetzt
auf und ist es hat man ist der westen
jetzt eigentlich geschlossener als
vorher oder war das vorher schon auch
ein gutes geschlossenes handeln was aber
leider ja nicht weiter gefruchtet hat
ja ich glaube beide nun herunter die
linken haben sehr gute arbeit gemacht
die letzten sechs monaten um europa und
den westen wirklich zusammen zu
schweißen da gab es kritik vor einem
halben jahr aus beiden und tut in genf
getroffen haben dass die amerikaner die
europäer gar nichts zu hören die haben
zugehört die waren über den hauptstädten
in europa die haben die die westliche
bundesheer gut zusammengehalten haben
die in geheimdienst- informationen ganz
offenbar teilt ganz hopfen verbreitet um
die länder hier einer gruppe zusammen
halte ich habe selten europas so
geeinigt gesehen natus so geeinigt wie
jetzt das ist ein positiver faktor von
dem ganzen nicht glaubt seit gestern
abend hat wenig endet die amerikaner
waren vorbereitet auf diese diese ersten
angriff die haben das gewalt seit wochen
die wussten haben auch gespottet rüber
es gibt kein krieger mittwoch das begann
dann am sonntag oder montag es egal aber
die geheimdienstinformationen war sehr
gut und ich glaube
sie haben sieht man man muss doch sagen
die diplomatie war doch nicht
erfolgreich
es gab geheimdienstinformationen dass
dieser krieg hätte vor zwei drei wochen
beginnen können und die die ganz offene
information über diesen diese ton der
krieg hat vielleicht den krieg oder der
anfang jetzt bis ende april bis ende
februar hinausgeschoben und
geheimdienste denken es gibt nur ein
kleines fenster wenden wenn das land
gefroren ist und das land wird nicht
mehr so lang lager gefahren sein da kann
angeblich die russische panzer nicht so
nicht so gut durchkommen wenn es nicht
mehr gefragt ist wer weiß was eigentlich
passiert ist aber der westen ist
zusammengeschlossenen deutschland hat
jetzt dort stream zweigeteilter gekippt
und das ist doch positiv dass der westen
droht mit mit ernsthafte sanktionen
der eu staaten haben sich auf scharfe
sanktionen auch geeinigt frau ist er
also wie empfinden sie die reaktion des
westens jetzt im vergleich zu 2
2 1014 finde ich schon dass der
erpressten sehr einig auftritt
wir wissen noch nicht welche sanktionen
jetzt in auf den weg geleitet werden und
ich glaube das ist das wichtigste aber
ein positives zeichen war schon mit
blick auf neustem 2 und ich wollte noch
mal auf die strategische kommunikation
zurückkommen ich finde dass es zum
ersten mal den westen gelungen ist diese
öffentliche resonanz zu haben für die
ukraine 2014 haben wir das nicht gehabt
und eigentlich bot ihm konnte damals
ohne konsequenzen die criminale act
ihren und die invasion im osten der
ukraine beginnen und ich glaube diese
öffentliche resonanz so die journalistin
beigetragen haben hatte wirklich jetzt
dazu geführt dass wir keinen großen
krieg in der ukraine haben und bot ihm
dafür entschieden hat über separatisten
zu viel zu gehen und das ist in dem
zusammenhang sollten wir nicht vergessen
wir haben eine hybride einen hybriden
krieg und das ist immer schwierig
manchmal die verbrecher sozusagen beim
namen zu nennen also die eu hat eben
scharfe sanktionen beschlossen darunter
gehört ein handelsverbot für russische
staatsanleihen und eine ganz mehrere
hundert personen unternehmen sollen auf
die eu sanktionsliste
kommen herr forscher dass sie jetzt
eigentlich und auch so schnell reagiert
was kann das bewirkt was hilft das dann
wirklich ich bin noch nicht so sicher
dass die eu geschlossen reagieren wir
haben unterschiedliche stimmen gehört es
gibt eu-außenminister die für einen
harten kurs plädiert haben ich nenne
jetzt nur mal die baltischen staaten
polen es gab staaten die das nicht
wollten zum beispiel österreich und
andere also ich sehe die eu noch nicht
so wahnsinnig geschlossen in dieser
sache und zu ihrer frage die diplomatie
hat nichts bewirkt das würde ich nicht
sagen das wissen wir nicht nur wir
müssen 1 natürlich ganz offen sagen wenn
ein land russland sich entschlossen hat
militärische gewalt anzuwenden
dann kann man das dann kann es sein dass
diplomatie das nicht verhindern kann das
ist möglich das müssen wir einfach
einräumen dass aber nicht an scheitern
von diplomatie sondern dass es dann das
eben ein staat unbedingt militärische
gewalt anwenden möchte und ich finde es
sehr interessant dass wir jetzt hier so
ein disput darüber haben also ich habe
die rede von putin gestern gehört dass
wir hier einen vertreter des kreml haben
wir lauf haben wir uns sagt putin hätte
das nicht gesagt was er gesagt hat und
dass das finde ich hoch problematisch
wir haben das in den letzten wochen
mehrfach erlebt dass wladimir putin der
präsident etwas gesagt hat und hinter
hieß es das hätte doch nicht gesagt er
hat abzüge angekündigt die dann nicht
stattgefunden haben und das zielt
natürlich alles auf unsere psyche
genauso wie russische übungen mit
atomwaffen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen übungen mit atomwaffen das
zielt auch auf die deutsche psyche und
die raketen die in kaliningrad
stationiert sind wir müssen offen
aussprechen können dass so etwa das ist
ein widerspruch zur un-charta das ist
ein widerspruch zur friedensordnung und
die abhängigkeit ist gegenseitig
russland kann auf unsere abhängigkeit
von russischem gas verweisen aber dann
können wir auch sagen russland ist
abhängig von unseren petrodollars die
wir dafür bezahlen und wir im westen
müssen uns überlegen ob das noch zu
verantworten ist dass wir dem kreml die
dollars und die euros geben mit denen er
die aggression finanziert abhängig von
russlands gas 55 prozent unserer ganzen
front kommt als helferin sehr spät
aufgewacht die eu kommissionspräsident
in hatte am wochenende gesagt das hat
auch die bundesregierung gesagt wir sind
jetzt in der lage über diesen winter zu
kommen natürlich ist diese
ersatzversorgung mit flüssiggas sehr
viel teurer als das russische gas aber
wenn wir diesen preis bezahlen müssen
damit wir sozusagen der kreml
kriegsmaschine das geld entziehen dann
glaube ich ist es verantwortungsvoll das
zumindest zu überlegen er werde putin
hat ja immer gesagt er fühle sich
bedroht durch die nato und das geht er
hätte es ging um das
sicherheitsbedürfnis russlands ist die
sicherheit russlands jetzt erhöht durch
die ecke anerkennung der republiken
durch sein agieren hat er dadurch die
dass sich die sicherheit von russland
erhöhen können
ich sitze dann auch die worte von herrn
marshall dann auch
kommentieren herr masche genauso was sie
sagen dass einfluss auf die psyche von
russischen russlands bürgern genau so
was sie dann auch mit den worten spielen
es geht nicht also da sollten wir
aufhören russland hat niemals darauf
hingewiesen dass ihre gas als eine waffe
benutzen kann das hat frau von der leyen
gesagt jetzt mit stolz zu stoppen wird
ein preis von münchen conference
wirkungen haben helmut schmid und kissen
hätten sie es geschehen dass solche
preise für solche leute die dann auch
von der waffe sprechen dass auch
russland unter dem druck gesetzt werden
kann dass auch europa auf russischen gas
verzichtet russland hat niemals gesagt
dass sie gashahn zudreht sicherheit eine
gute frage also im grunde genommen
man versucht sie jetzt
westen nato
berlin paris brüssel zu einem gespräch
einladen
brötchen sagt kein krieg waffenruhe also
das sollten jetzt stillstand man sie
akzeptiere ich aber nicht erwartet dass
er sagt mir ist kein abkommen sollten
jetzt also das ist ein schluss
eigentlich das war viel früher residenz
geht der männer ausgesagt hat alles was
von schenker unterzeichnet hat es war
unter der pistole gegen stirn das
erfüllen wir nicht mehrmals gesagt und
mehrweg und nicht traurig der
botschafter wenig und minister kollege
hat das auch dann bestätigt dies gab
kommen nicht am 10 februar haben die
politischen berater haben versucht die
beiden publikum zu gesprächen geladen
geld nicht sicherheit eine offene frage
ja das war dann auch so hat er die
sicherheit erhöht
das war die einladung das war die
einladung gehört zu weiteren gesprächen
über die sicherheit es jetzt sinn von
durchschnitt wenn auch besten das anders
als drohung bezeichnet hat dass es eine
seite sonst das war eine einladung doch
zu sehen dass vorstand hat die sorge
dass die gleichen manier von atomwaffen
natürlich macht auch nato infrastruktur
steht dann die grenze das in wenigen
stunden zigtausend truppen können
tatsächlich dann
einmarsch in summe also ja zu anderen
wirklichkeit aber es
stehen keine nato truppen an der grenze
sondern es stehen russische truppen an
der ukrainischen grenze
ein paar tagen wurde auch die kontakt
linien beschossen und wir wissen dass
zum ersten mal seit 2016 würden zivile
sie wieder infrastruktur beschossen der
kindergarten wurde beschossen die
schulden wurden beschossen in einer
stadt gab es gibt es ja jetzt jetzt
keine keinen strom und gibt es probleme
mit wasser versorgen das alles kann aus
der sogenannten
eigentlich würde ich sagen das wurde
auch auf guten willen von puten das
alles gemacht weil ist es schwierig
immer über separatisten zu sprechen und
dass das erfolgte leider und das und ich
möchte noch mal auch mit
hinweisen er hat in seiner rede gestern
auch gesagt
als er dann erklären wollte warum die
anerkennung der republiken stattfinden
soll hat er gesagt ja am anfang wird es
uns weh tun aber wir sollten uns nicht
davon abschrecken und wir hatten schon
das 2008 erlebt unter westen wird mit
der zeit wieder höher die partnerschaft
mit uns schließen das ist ein sehr
schwieriges zu sagen spiele und selbst
für viele spiel würde ich sagen und das
ist wirklich jetzt hängt sehr viel vom
westen ab ob wir einen so langen atem
haben um mit so einem autoritären staat
umzugehen auf was muss man sich da ein
stimmen die sagen langen atem was denken
sie von marschall also was was beginnt
da ja jetzt was er natürlich hat das
jetzt schon eine lange geschichte aber
es seit gestern hatte man erwähnt es ist
ja doch ein wendepunkt ja ich kann nur
noch mal wiederholen aus meiner sicht
ist das was gestern und in den tagen
passiert ist eine zäsur
russland versucht eine andere ordnung in
europa mit militärischer gewalt zu
erzwingen wenn herr bin oft hier sagt
essständen tausende russische soldaten
vor der russischen grenze wir wissen
doch es stimmt doch überhaupt nicht es
ist einfach gelogen die nächste flüge es
stehen nicht tausende nato soldaten vor
der russischen grenze sondern es stehen
weit über hundert tausend russische
soldaten an vier fronten an der
ukrainischen grenze im besetzten
transnistrien dass die seit 30 jahren
ein teil der republik moldau die eu
anwärter land ist halt hält russland
seit 30 jahren besetzt dort haben sie
eine front sie haben im vergangen haben
vor acht jahren die crema over dort ist
die nächste front sie haben sie gehen
von der russischen grenze in die ost
ukraine hinein und jetzt haben wir auch
noch mal war in belarus also von der
nordgrenze der ukraine und auch dort die
nächste lügen ich hat sowohl herr putin
wie die generalität gesagt dieses
manöver wird mit dem ende der
olympischen spiele in belarus beendet
die russischen truppen werden sich in
die kasernen zurückziehen der nächste
bruch warum glauben sie ist es so
einfach und lügen zu erzählen die jeder
überprüfen kann dass sie nicht stimmen
die frage ist aber warum hat man aber
dass er gesagt ja was gesagt sie haben
gesagt was sie hatte sehr sicher gesagt
wo von nato erlaubt in wenigen stunden
die truppen einzumarschieren das habe
ich gesagt und das ist genau was sie
machen das ist nicht korrekt weil gerade
hier dass sie schon genauso meine worte
falsch einschätzen wie kann ich auch
ihren glauben für uns bringen truppen
das nicht wissen sie herr maschen
wieviel hunderttausende sowjetbürger in
dieser übergangszeit in moldova in
tadschikistan im südkaukasus erschossen
wurden waren warum lügen sie und erzählt
diese geschichte nicht genau die
russische armee also liegt es
stillgelegt hat hunderttausende
erschossen okay das wissen sie genau was
passiert hat aber ich denke spätestens
transnistrien erschossen worden davon
weiß ich würde ich würde gerne würde er
bella ich würde gerne diskussion ich
würde die diskussion wieder auf die
ukraine gerne und das jetzige verhalten
von putin gerne lenken und noch mal
fragen hatten die frage an herrn
kirschbaum die ukraine hat ja lange
gesagt sind sie braucht viel mehr
unterstützung sie brauchen auch
militärische hilfe was wäre denn wenn es
jetzt wirklich zu einem richtigen
einmarsch kommt einem oder wendigen die
militärische provokation weitergeht was
wären denn die usa auch militärisch
bereit zu leisten um der ukraine zu
helfen ja es wird keiner mehr es würden
auf keinen fall amerikaner jack und
kragen gehen und in diesem krieges
unterstützen habe keine deutsche keinen
nato soldaten nein aber die melodie die
engländer und dänemark und ein paar
anderen haben defensive waffen geliefert
und ukraine vielleicht kommen mehr
natürlich wäre schön wenn deutschland
auch waffen hätte liefern können an
ukraine um sich selbst zu beteiligen um
den preis hochzutreiben von der mögliche
us invasion von von ukraine aber nein
deutschland bei kauf lieber die waffen
gibt den katar und saudi arabien und
behauptet die wollen keine waffen in
gefährliche bieten schicken das ist
schon eine kuriose
fakten die ganze welt jetzt gesehen hat
in dieser ukraine krise
es wird keinen krieg um ukraine geben
natur wird da nicht involviert sein das
ist eine gute sache eigentlich die
amerikaner seit anfang der ende der
kalten krieg george bush hat gesagt in
schicken kiew speed wir werden hier
nicht sein und es gibt in amerika
momentan übrigens auch eine lebendige
diskussion war das ein fehler in 97 die
nato-erweiterung nach osteuropa
auszudehnen das hat viele merken das
nicht machen wollen viele wissen experte
es ist seriös halten den medien jetzt in
den zeitungen wird das lebendigste
diskutiert diese entscheidung von bill
clinton 96 ungarn polen der
tschechoslowakei war ein zu lassen aber
das war eine ganz andere welt damals
hieß es aus russland könnte so nato
kommen
während felix stiffel aber
es war ein ganzes land muss man warte
gejagt das war eine ganz andere dort
aber dato wird nicht weiter nach ukraine
ukraine wird nicht teil von nato und von
daher wird diese krieg hoffentlich keine
große kriegt das wird niemandem etwas
erhofft sich die ukraine die ja klar
gesagt hat sie will eigentlich oder sie
wünscht sich mehr militärische
unterstützung auch jetzt noch mal mit
dieser aktuellen entwicklung was braucht
die ico ihnen jetzt vom westen die
ukraine hat nie darum gebeten dass die
nato-truppen in der ukraine stationiert
werden es geht wirklich um die stärkung
der ukrainischen armee 2014 hat die
ukraine eine so niederlage erlebt und
das war für viele ukraine auch schwer
das sozusagen zu ertragen viele haben
auch der ukrainischen armen geholfen
auch die ukrainische diaspora wurden
schutzwesten in die ukraine
transportiert und deswegen geht es jetzt
heutzutage nicht um die nato
stationierung in der ukraine
es gibt sogar um fragen die vor kurzem
durchgeführt wurden das circa 50 prozent
der bevölkerung sind bereit der
ukrainischen armee zu helfen und als die
hälfte davon möchte auch in die
ukrainische armee gehen und wenn es zu
einem krieg konnte und heute und jetzt
ist es für den westen sehr wichtig
diesen langen atem zu haben erst mal
die ukraine weiterhin stärken ich finde
das schön das ist schon aber dann hab
ich die tierischen genauer trittin
material militärischen mit der reale und
zweitens weiß ich schon gesagt
die ukraine erlebt heutzutage eine
hybride kriegsführung jeden monat das
sind neuen schätzungen verliert die
ukraine circa 3 milliarden us-dollar
wenn wir über wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen dieser truppen
stationierung an den grenzen der ukraine
ist sprechen das ist alles eine
bedrohung für die ukraine wieder
investoren möchten jetzt in die jüngeren
nicht investieren und die dritte
dimension noch dazu das ist der diese
informations kriegen der betrieben wird
das findet über social media statt über
verschiedene kanäle und einige kanäle
sind auch in der ukraine zu empfangen
und da sind die fronten und bei diesen
fronten braucht die ukraine
unterstützung bräuchte sie da mehr
herrscher müsste dann wenn klar ist dass
die usa dass die nato nicht eingreifen
wird das ist ja völlig klar aber ist
dass letztendlich dann auch ja eine
schwächung und ist das also welchen
welche mittel hat man denn dann müsste
man nicht irgendwo anders helfen das
beste was man für die ukraine tun kann
ist ihr helfen ihre staatlichkeit zu
stärken ihre wirtschaft zu stärken und
da zeigt sich ja auch was die wirkliche
gefahr ist die von der ukraine für
russland ausgeht es gibt ja eine gefahr
das ist ja keine militärische gefahr
sondern die größte sorge die putin hat
ist dass die länder die zwischen
russland und dem westen liegen sich
erfolgreich entwickeln können als
marktwirtschaft als demokratie die
ukraine ist heute überhaupt kein ideales
land es gibt dort große probleme mit
korruption
es gibt dort große probleme bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit es gibt einfach auch
von der struktur also alles was wir tun
können ist der ukraine zu helfen wie
auch den staaten die vor
transformationsstaaten waren zu
demokratien zu rechtsstaaten zu
marktwirtschaften dazu werde russland
auch genauso helfen was sagen gewohnt
das sind ja da zu stärken das angebot
ist ja da aber ich meine wir können wir
können eine regierung deren macht darauf
beruht dass die autoritär ist und dass
sie die meinungsvielfalt unterdrückt und
dass die position nicht in die medien
kommt und die oppositionsführer mit
giftgas
mit giftgas mitgift anschlägen mit
trifft anschlägen versucht zu ermorden
mehr als anbieten können wie russland
nicht dass wir gerne russland auf diesem
weg mit dabei haben wollen zur
demokratie zur rechtsstaatlichkeit aber
wir können sozusagen uns nicht darauf
einlassen dass weil herr putin das für
eine gefahr hält dass die ukraine oder
die republik moldau oder belarus
erfolgreich sein könnte dass ihr deshalb
diese
guten entwicklung versucht mit allen
möglichkeiten zu unterbinden und das
möchte ich noch mal sagen es wäre mir
wirklich wichtig wer wie ich habe kein
problem und keine feindschaft mit dem
russischen volk überhaupt nicht ich habe
dort sehr gute freunde aber ich habe ein
problem mit der russischen führung und
wie sie sich verhält und wenn wir
darüber reden wollen was sie gesagt
haben wie kann man sich gegenseitig
helfen dass wir eine positive
entwicklung haben herr die luft da haben
sie mich sofort auf ihrer seite herbede
etwas wie sehr würden denn die
sanktionen russland treffen und auch der
dass das aufkündigen vom 22
also vielen dank das trifft sie die
einfachen russe nicht gut in die sonne
umgeben die küche kommen nicht zu
verstehen ich bin ich hier nicht im
auftrag und geschminkt als propagandist
republik 300 meter vom kreml entfernt
aber unabhängig sanktionen
treffen klein und mittelunternehmen
hier sollte mich also die wissenschaft
wollen wir dann auch probleme mit
platzierung haben werden etc und im
grunde genommen wir bekommen da sollten
wir noch darüber sprechen ob die
sanktionen von jona amerikaner
völkerrechtlich sind es gibt ohne und
uns berechtigt diese sanktion
einzuführen
russland hat jemals als erstes land
funktion angeführt das waren immer die
gegen einschränkung maßnahmen und ich
glaube nicht dass die sanktionen wie es
auch die acht jahren gezeigt haben
die zielgruppe also die macht die
gehobene machen die höchste macht
treffen wird wenn es das ziel ist dass
die wählerschaft in russland dann
bisschen absetzen
als zur wunsch bekommen würde das ist
dann auch dann falsch und das ist
vielleicht auch nicht das
sonst jetzt was ihr jetzt aus washington
bekommen aus brüssel bekommen haben ich
glaube dass ein falscher weg und der
masche lichdi wozu wir sollten
tatsächlich
in der diskussion bleiben wie es weiter
machen es gibt dann auch eine neue
generation ist bin schon fünfmal kurs
vater kaum zu glauben wir sprechen mit
meinen kinder die schon auch zum
mittleren version gehören und da sehe
ich das sehr vieles in köpfen sich
ändert und das sollte dann auch der
westen sehen und dies im sinne gesunken
wer aber welche show welche chance haben
dann junge menschen wenn die opposition
wenn die keinen kein recht hat sich zu
äußern wenn wenn wenn die preise nicht
frei ist in russland das ist doch ein
ganz großes problem
es gibt internet und glauben sie mir wie
viel es auch bei jungen im internet
passiert ich gerate immer junge leute zu
wahllokalen zu kommen und so peinlich
wenig mitbekommen und 30 prozent 20
prozent ihres prozent sehen einige leute
mir sagen ich habe häufig komme nicht
weil es auch nichts bringt da wenig
dagegen es gibt einen teil neue neue
leute oder menschen kritisieren sie dass
es quasi ein projekt von kreml ist
vielleicht aber ich gerne viele leute
von dort und das ist meine hoffnung noch
einmal
wir haben eine hoffnung auf einer neuen
generation ist genau wie haben nicht
mehr so viel zeit frauen
haben welche hoffnung haben sie jetzt im
moment dass ich noch etwas
verbessert das ist eben nichts zu dieser
großen kriegerischen auseinandersetzung
die situation die wir ihm 2014 haben
nicht nie wieder sich wiederholen wird
dass wir nie zulassen dass die ukraine
jetzt aus unserer öffentlichen
aufmerksamkeit verschwindet und das der
westen mit mit zeit einfach sagt wir
haben jetzt keine kraft
energie und wir können uns um unsere
wirtschaftliche beziehungen mit russland
ich glaube wir haben jetzt ein
paradigmenwechsel und wir müssen leider
viele momente ändern und das wird park
das wird schmerzhaft für uns alle aber
es geht heute um die grundprinzipien die
wir verteidigen der internationalen
rechtsordnung und wir entscheiden heute
in welchem system wir in zukunft leben
werden werden wir autoritären macht
erleben oder das recht genießen der
kirschbaum welche hoffnung haben sie wo
denken sie jetzt auch gerade in den
nächsten tagen was ja wo man noch
ansetzen kann was erwarten sie da
ja ich glaube es wird ein langer prozess
jetzt ich glaube diese sanktionen werden
lange da sein und ob die deutschen zb
das alles mitmachen wollen wenn energie
teurer wird und so medien hat schon
heute gedroht dass der gast teuer wird
das dass ich bin gespannt ob der westen
zusammenbleiben kann halt bleiben kann
das kann wirklich lange dauert ich ich
lese umfragen hier in deutschland wieder
erstaunt wie viel sympathie das putten
genießt vor allem in ostdeutschland wo
ich wohne umfragen zeigen fast so viele
deutsche hier im osten geben die usa die
verantwortung für diese spannung ukraine
und nicht putten das erstaunt mich immer
wieder wie viel sympathie puten hat hier
in deutschland es wird eine schwierige
zeit deutschland ist gesehen vom außen
oft aus der schwächste glied in der
kette hier viele villen auf deutschland
gucken wird deutschland mitmachen mit
dieses sanktionen die wenn empfindlich
sein die werden wehtun die deutschen
werden die konsequenzen spüren wie die
wussten das ist die frage würden die
deutschen noch so bei der stange bleiben
oder ist das jetzt nur eine kurzfristige
phase wo alle eng zusammen rudern
was denken sie wie wird das in
deutschland aufgefasst wird man da
weiter mit das mittragen auch wenn es
uns dann letztendlich irgendwo auch
trifft ich glaube schon also heute war
eigentlich bundeskanzler scholz der
klarste was sofort die konkreten
sanktionen zu denen er bereit ist
betrifft klarer als die eu oder die wir
schon vorhin gesprochen haben und meine
hoffnung ich habe sozusagen gestapelte
hoffnung meine erste hoffnung wäre dass
der angriff auf der ost ukraine also die
beiden ob platz im moment kontrollieren
die separatisten ja gar nicht die
gebiete komplett auf die russland
anspruch erhebt dass das zu einem
nachdenken führt ich bin da leider nicht
sehr optimistisch so viele truppen
widerstehen meine zweite hoffnung wäre
dass es wenn es schon ein angriff gibt
er sich regional begrenzt bleibt er
nicht auf die ganze ukraine nicht auf
kiew geht und wir die chance haben die
ukraine mit unserer hilfe dass die
ukraine sich weiterentwickelt
demokratischer wird
marktwirtschaftlicher wird und zeigt
dass es eben sehr wohl geht in dieser
gegenden rechtsstaaten demokratie und
marktwirtschaft zu entwickeln und dass
dieses klare signal auch putin
hoffentlich davon abhält nicht noch
weiter zu gehen das ist meine art auch
dann noch ein stärkeres signal wenn
deutschland sich auch sagen würde wenn
würde mehr mehr mehr waffen liefern
der besuch ist glaube ich abgefahren für
den moment im moment stehen weit über
hunderttausend truppen es gibt
unterschiedliche zahlen ob das 113
160000 sie stehen nicht nur an einer
freund sie stehen ich sage nochmal an
vier fronten ja im osten im norden im
süden und im südwesten transnistrien im
besetzten transnistrien
da kann man nicht sehr viel tun außer zu
sagen der preis wird sehr hoch für für
putin aber die politisch musters gelöst
höher ist sollte politisch gelöst werden
und vielleicht gibt ja dann doch noch
eine chance für die diplomatie das
hoffen natürlich alle vielen dank herr
mag frau merkel und herr kirsch warum
vielen dank liebe zuschauer ihnen für
das interesse für diese phoenix-runde
bestandsschutz
[Musik]